Salut les mentalos ! Aujourd'hui je suis avec mon pote Max. Salut Max !
-Salut !
-Max, si vous ne le connaissez pas, ce qui m'étonnerai... Mais si vous ne le connaissez pas, vous pouvez cliquer sur sa tête !
-Voilà !
-Il démontre des idées reçues sur Internet.
-Tout à fait !
-Et alors aujourd'hui je t'ai invité pour parler de Pi parce qu'il y a une grande idée reçue sur Pi, sur le nombre Pi.
-Ouais.
-Pi. Tu vois Pi ?
-Pi, oui complètement: 3,14...
-Et bien, à l'intérieur de toutes ces décimales il y a une idée reçue.
Est-ce que tu sais laquelle ?
...
-Non.
[rires]
-Il hésite parce que je lui ai dit avant en fait ! [rires]
-Oui, alors je me suis dis est-ce que je fais semblant de savoir ou pas...
On pense que c'est un nombre univers, ce qui veut dire qu'en fait, dans toutes les décimales de Pi, il y a toutes les combinaisons possibles de chiffres.
-Un nombre univers, c'est ça. C'est un nombre qui a des décimales à l'infini, mais elles ne sont pas périodiques, elles ne sont pas cycliques.
C'est comme si on faisait 10/3, ça fait 3,33333333333...
-Donc ça c'est périodique, ça c'est cyclique ?
-Ca, oui !
-C'est cyclique. Il y a 3, puis encore 3, puis encore 3...
-Extactement.
Mais ça pourrait etre aussi 456456456456...
Et dans un nombre univers, on peut retrouver toutes les séquences possibles.
Il y a par exemple, votre âge, avec mon âge, avec le numéro de carte bleue de Max Bird.
-Et il y a aussi tout le roman Hamlet dedans, techniquement.
-C'est vrai. Et il y a même tout le roman Hamlet mais avec personnage principal, Harry Potter.
-Ah ouais !
-Il y a toutes les possibilités, tu vois ce que veux dire ?
-Ce qui serait mieux d'ailleurs !
-Oui ! [rires]
-Les gens le liraient plus.
-Oui.
Il y a aussi forcément un endroit où il y a 16 millions de zéros.
Puisqu'il y a toutes les possiblités !
[rires]
-Et 17 millions de zéros aussi.
-Exactement !
-Ah ! C'est horrible ! [rires]
C'est hyper gênant comme pensée en fait...
Ca veut dire qu'il y a aussi le film, le troisième film "The dark night",
la version avec Heath Ledger s'il n'était pas mort.
-Exactement.
Et si on change un pixel par un chiffre, il y a la Joconde.
Mais il y a la Joconde avec la cicatrice d'Harry Potter aussi !
[rires]
Ce qui serait encore mieux encore une fois !
-Mais bien sûr !
-En fait il faut mettre Harry Potter partout, ça marcherait beaucoup mieux.
-Donc on pressent que Pi est comme ça, mais il y a une idée reçue où on lit souvent dans des magazines, dans des revues, même parfois dans des revues scientifiques vulgarisées,
que Pi est un nombre univers, on n'en sait rien, on le pressent.
-D'accord ! Alors ce n'est pas une idée reçue totale, il y a un doute.
-On le pressent. C'est comme racine de 2, on pressent que c'est ça mais on ne peut pas le prouver, on n'en ait pas encore certain de toute manière.
C'est vraiment un doute. Ce n'est pas...
-Mais le jour où on en sera certain, ça ne changera pas le calcul du cercle ou quoi que ce soit...?
-Non.
-Voilà ! Ca, ça marchera tout le temps.
-Oui, ça marchera tout le temps.
-Bon, très bien. [rires]
-Tu imagines le jour où tu découvres un truc scientifique, ça ne marche plus !
-En fait tous les cercles sont des carrés, on s'est fait avoir depuis le début...
-Imagines, non, en fait les avions ne peuvent pas voler !
Boom !
[rires]
-Ça change tout.
-Ce n'est pas possible.
Il y a un jeu qui s'est organisé autour de Pi, c'est assez fabuleux,
ce sont des personnes qui apprennent les décimales de Pi.
-Ah ouais !
-Donc ils se sont organisé à apprendre ça.
Le record du monde, non validé, c'est un japonais à la retraite. Un ancien ingénieur.
Il a mémorisé 100 000 décimales de Pi.
-Déjà à la base compter jusqu'à 100 000 pendant 16H, c'est déjà un exploit ! [rires]
alors retenir l'ordre, et en plus du coup il y n'a aucune logique !
-Ah oui ! Non ! C'est ça qui est très drôle !
C'est complètement irrationnel quoi...
Alors il n'a pas été validé par le "Guinness Book", il n'était pas là le jour là.
-Donc nous on va le faire ! Vous avez 16H !
[rires]
Et on espère bien que le "Guinness Book" va le valider !
Par contre, le mec qui a été validé au "Guiness", c'est 67 000 décimales.
C'est déjà pas mal.
-C'est déjà pas mal...
-C'est déjà pas mal.
[rires]
-Il y a vraiment des gens qui n'ont rien à foutre !
-C'est ça. C'est de me dire la démarche, en fait comment tu fais... tu...
-Moi, j'ai un rêve dans la vie, c'est de faire les 68 000 décimales de Pi.
-C'est ça.
-En fait rien que 1000... Le fait d'avoir rajouté 1000, déjà ça me fait suer.
[rires]
-Mais quel est le quotidien d'apprentissage ?
-Olala...
-Ce sont les passions de ces mecs.
-Je ne sais pas...
-Est-ce que tu trouves ça ridicule ?
-Ah oui, je trouve ça ridicule.
-Voilà...!
-Mais je trouvais ça classe dans le film, dans "...et les 17 Pi",
où le mec il s'appelle Pi, donc tout le monde se fou de sa gueule parce que pipi pi pi,
et pour que les gens arrêtent de le ridiculiser, et bien il apprend par cœur et il bluffe tout le monde avec ça.
Là c'est classe !
-Moi perso, j'ai appris les 10 000 premières décimales quand même.
-Ah énorme !
T'as appris les 10 000 toi ?!
-C'est ça.
C'est pour ça, ça me faisait très plaisir que tu me dises que ce soit ridicule !
[rires]
-Non en fait c'est pas que c'est ridicule...
Non ! En fait, j'ai pas dit ça...
-Ce n'est pas ça du tout que je voulais dire...!
-En fait, ce que je veux dire, si les gens le font, c'est pas qu'ils n'ont rien à faire c'est qu'ils ont un don de mémorisation.
Et il me semble que tu as un don de mémorisation.
-Non, je me passionne en tout cas pour mémoriser des choses, ça m'intéresse vachement quoi !
-Ouais, mais même je me souviens. Je l'ai déjà vu en spectacle !
Plusieurs fois !
Et que je suis assez bluffé par ta capacité à mémoriser mais des...trucs à une vitesse incroyable quoi !
D'ailleurs je vais essayer de le faire avec toi. Pour le première fois je vais essayer, publiquement en fait, de te montrer comment ça marche dans ma tête
et si j'arrive à retrouver une séquence ou pas.
Tu prends Pi où tu veux.
-Ouais.
-Et tu vas me lire une séquence de 5 chiffres.
-Et tu vas retrouver l'autre ?!
-Je vais essayer en fait de compléter.
Si tu me dis par exemple: 5-6-1-9-0, ici, il faut que je te complète...
-D'accord. Et c'est la ligne qui est en-dessous, pas de l'autre page.
-Oui, moi j'ai appris dans ce sens là parce que c'est vraiment dans ce sens là qu'elles existent en fait.
Voilà, oui c'est ça.
-Ok ! Alors si ça marche on est sur le point de vivre quelque chose d'exceptionnel quand même.
Hein ?!
-Et si je fais une petite erreur aussi d'ailleurs.
[rires]
-Parce qu'il serait beaucoup plus humain finalement !
Ah ! Mais ça me stresse ! Parce que là il n'y a pas de trucage, je ne sais vraiment vraiment pas laquelle choisir.
-Mais ce n'est pas grave si je fais des petites erreurs...
-Oui, oui, déjà si tu en trouves...
[rires]
Ah c'est incroyable.
Ok alors attention on y va.
1-3-0-9-6-7.
-1-3-0...? Parce que déjà il faut que je retienne tout ce que tu viens de me dire.
-Oui, bien sûr.
-1-3-0...
9-6-7.
-C'est impossible.
- 9-6-7...
1-3-0-9-6-7... C'est ce qui va me prendre le plus de temps c'est de retrouver où c'est.
-D'accord.
-9...
7... [réfléchi]
7...
9-6-7...
1-3-0-9-6-7.
-Ouais.
-2
C'est ça ?
-C'est ça, c'est ça ! Il n'y a aucune erreur !
-5
-Ouais.
-J'ai bon jusque là ?
-Ouais ouais c'est tout bon, c'est tout bon !
-Attends, ça va me revenir...
-C'est un alien !
-3
-Attends.
Là il y a une erreur.
-3-1-4 ?
-Ouais.
-3-1-4-5...
[rires]
-0...
Etc, etc...
-Oh ! Ah mais c'est incroyable ! Bravo !
Bravo !
-Merci !
-Mais c'est incroyable ! Attends mais tu connais tout le bouquin ! [étonné]
-Oui du coup.
Merci d'être venu.
-Mais merci à toi.
-Merci d'être venu ici, dans le décor du Mental Vlog.
-Ouais, carrément, je vois enfin où tu tournes toutes tes vidéos, et ça me tue parce que
j'ai envie de dire pourquoi tu n'as pas fait 20 000 vidéos pour montrer à tout le monde que tu sais faire ça, c'est incroyable !
[rires]
Parce que le mec il fait une vidéo par jour et chaque jour il te sort un truc comme ça, mais c'est incroyable !
-Merci en tout cas d'être venu.
Merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Si vous aussi vous vous amusez à mémoriser des fois des trucs qui ne servent à rien, mettez le dans les commentaires, ça me ferais plaisir et je me sentirais beaucoup moins seul.
[rires]
-Moi je mémorise beaucoup les répliques de films.
-Ah voilà, tu vois, ça n'a pas d'intérêt à la base, réel. Mais c'est un truc que tu kiffes.
-Même les noms latins de bestioles.
-Voilà.
-"Hopistocomus hoasin" ça ne sert à rien de le retenir, mais moi je ne sais pas pourquoi je...
-Et ça veut dire ?
-C'est le nom latin de l'oiseau qui a des petites griffes là.
C'est une sorte d'archéoptéryx, mais d'aujourd'hui.
-Tu vois, c'est une sorte d'archéoptéryx mais d'aujourd'hui...
Tu ne savais pas ça franchement ?
[rires]
-Ouais franchement c'est...
-Non, mais c'est marrant parce qu'on a tous des délires mentaux en fait.
Mettez nous votre délire mental dans les commentaires, on va créer une communauté comme ça.
-Tu risques d'avoir de trucs... enfin sur YouTube...
[rires]
Non, mais allez-y. J'irai regarder aussi.
Ça m'intéresse.
-Merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, si ça vous a plu, vous nous le faites savoir en nous laissant un petit, mais néanmoins "Pisant", pouce en l'air.
Vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaine avant de partir, puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H ou 11H, je ne sais plus.
Ciao !